I do have a baby it's like the gayest
thing about me actually is that I have a
baby like it's the new it's like the new
thing for gay people yeah like we
finally get to have babies how's it
going I love it I love being a mom it's
very still very new he's 11 weeks today
and so this has been a very intense time
like making the show two weeks after we
wrapped on the show my partner had the
baby I've been in baby zone now we're
back into TV Zone and speaking of TV The
Duo share how they chose the stars of
their new series Rayleigh and season
this twins no yes
take it what is this a business meeting
hey Twin Two got a name Sarah Tegan and
Sarah doesn't even rhyme your parents
flew it I know that they were found on
Tick Tock which is incredible and
life-changing for them but who was
scrolling Tick Tock I mean I was doing
the Doom scroll like we all do before
bed a little self-soothing and
um and a clip from Raley's Tick Tock
showed up but the video I saw was of her
giving a tour of her car and it was just
it was like watching me in high school
so first I have this thing and my phone
just sits up there with a magnet yeah I
sent it to Sarah and I said she's a twin
like go deep like check out all these
videos and then sir sent them to the
high school friends because we were like
is this crazy or like is this kind of
cool like did we just luck out and find
identical twins that kind of seemed like
us in high school
and they're also celebrating the release
of their new album cry baby
guy
tell me tell me where do we start 10th
studio album come on I looked up other
bands I have 10 albums out because I was
like you know is this like a normal
thing it's not a departure but it's
definitely a return in a way to some of
the things we've done in the past
we were like we don't want to just put
an album out to put an album out we got
to put something meaningful out we're
really excited we're gonna go out on
tour and support it I think it's a
really strong record
[Music]